health authorities across latin america
are battling a rise in coronavirus
infections
the region already has the highest
covert 19 death rate in the world
brazil has suffered the most fatalities
in the region with more than
half a million deaths that's followed by
mexico where
over 230 000 people have died and peru
has reported nearly 200
000 deaths dw's johann ramirez reports
from lima where the new
lambda variant is pushing the public
healthcare system to breaking point
in peru people are placing their hopes
for curbing the pandemic
on vaccination yet progress is slow
only some 15 percent of peruvians have
received at least one dose
one of the worst rates in latin america
but for health workers on the ground
it's better than nothing
we felt optimistic because people react
well to vaccination in peru
in fact younger people would like
everything to go faster so they can get
vaccinated soon although commerce has
reopened after a
nine month quarantine strict safety
measures remain in place
authorities have mandated using double
face masks to enter
stores and shopping centers face shields
are widely used and hand washing
facilities
had been installed in the streets but it
has not been enough
peru has the highest per capita death
rate in the world
the government's response to the crisis
has been widely
the criticized arrived too late
the management of the pandemic is a
complete disgrace
especially for the previous president's
one now at least the pfizer vaccine has
arrived
the last two peaks of infections in peru
have coincided
with deep political crisis that in both
cases
led to massive demonstrations the first
one was in november
when political instability led to three
presidents
in one week the second wave of protests
is happening right now the reason
a controversial presidential election
one of the candidates cried fraud while
the other
claimed there is a plan to steal his
victory supporters from both sides have
taken to the streets
according to some experts these
demonstrations could cause
a further rise in the infection curve
but at this point the country cannot
afford new lockdowns
the greatest effort must be done to
vaccinate
the population and to start negotiating
from now on
new generation vaccines for the new
variants that may appear
this is the most effective measure and
we have been slow in doing so
on average peru administers about 350
000 vaccines every week a low figure for
a country of more than
33 million authorities have promised
that the process will accelerate a
government forecast estimates
that the eligible population will be
immunized
by the end of 2021
cuba is expected to approve one of those
one of its vaccines against covert 19
in the coming days regulatory approval
for the shot called
abdallah could help speed up
vaccinations across latin america where
the case numbers
remain high but countries are struggling
to get shots
however public health officials are
calling for caution saying the vaccine
should be scrutinized by global drug
regulators before being used around the
world
a moment of celebration in havana last
month as cuban scientists announced the
results of their kova 19 vaccine trial
the shot's 92 reported efficacy rate
puts it in the same league as those
developed by pharma giants like the
biontech pfizer alliance
a remarkable achievement for a tiny
island of 11 million people
havana has five covet 19 vaccine
candidates in development
it's been vaccinating its own citizen
since may and last month started
shipping shots to venezuela
a point of national pride
we cubans help others things that other
countries in the world don't do
countries that have more possibilities
than we do and we help those in need
without any problem
cuba says 30 countries have expressed
interest in its vaccines
but public health officials and even
politicians are urging caution
cuba state biotech firm hasn't published
trial data yet or applied for approval
from the world health organization
if this vaccine is approved by the
international scientific community
we will welcome it but it must be
approved
we venezuelans should not be guinea pigs
but with no end in sight for latin
america's vaccine shortage
some are being forced to choose between
an unrecognized shot
or none at all